hey everyone and welcome in i appreciate
you joining us here on youtube we are
going live this is a bit of an
experiment but uh we're gonna try it out
i am dion robowen i am a markets
reporter here at the wall street journal
uh this is market takes and um thank you
for joining us we're gonna be talking
about all things markets the economy uh
really talking about the big drivers
what's moving the markets what's going
on in the real economy as well and right
now you know as i look out at things i'm
seeing three very big themes for the
week ahead uh we're gonna be talking
about
what we expect to see from the jobs
numbers that we get obviously this is
jobs week happy jobs week to everyone
out there
also the big theme in markets right now
as it has been really all year that's
that inflation data we're also going to
be talking about housing which i think
is a big piece that's feeding into
really this this whole inflation cost
prices all of that so welcome in to
market takes here on youtube and we are
live streaming again i'm dion robowen
from the wall street journal you guys
are on my page so i appreciate that
if you haven't subscribed please
subscribe and yeah we're gonna jump
right into everything going on like i
said with markets with the economy uh
with with all that so
want to get started first things first
and just check in on the markets on this
monday morning you know as we're looking
out the dow and the s p both in the red
slightly uh the dow down about 35 or
0.35 percent
the s p down about 0.1 percent the
nasdaq right now is positive holding on
to those gains from overnight session
also of course if you know me you know i
love bonds we are looking at the yield
curve right now we saw overnight an
inversion of that five-year and 30-year
treasury
that just you know it's one of the big
signals that investors watch for it's
not the big inversion that everyone
really worries about that's the two year
and the ten year but the five year in
the third year really does signal that
we are starting to see a changing of
inflation expectations and of
expectations for the real economy um so
we saw that five-year 30-year inversion
that's definitely something to keep your
eye on and the difference between the
two-year and the 10-year yield the
10-year is still higher but barely i
think right now we are holding on by
about 18 basis points the 10-year being
higher than the two-year so
really watch for that i just did a video
about the yield curve inversion what it
means why it's such an accurate
predictor of recession so if you haven't
check that out it's on the page you can
watch that we also of course our team or
excuse me our
wsj video team did a great video about
you know doing a real deep dive on the
yield
conversion so watch that video after
market takes of course after the live
stream uh and check that out as well
again the s p right now we are negative
but if the s p can close higher i think
that level is about 45 87 we will move
out of correction territory the s p has
been in correction territory for 23 days
if we get out today it would be 24 days
in that correction territory moving back
into potentially a bull market scenario
so keep an eye on that we are for those
of you who love the technical analysis
we are hitting that 61.8 level on the
fibonacci uh retracement scale so if you
like technical analysis you know what
that means if you don't don't worry
about it it's not important we're going
to get into the fundamentals and what's
really moving the markets this week and
looking back at last week
so as we talked about last week i want
to point to
the big
the the big event last week and that
started on monday it was fed it was
federal reserve chair jerome powell
talking to the national association for
business economics gave a speech there
where he said you know what we could
really start to think about and 50 basis
points at a meeting
a raising rates is in play for those of
you who don't follow the fed every
single day of your life
usually the fed raises rates by 25 basis
points at each meeting or when they're
raising rates they raise by 25 basis
points one quarter of one percent what
pal is saying is they could double that
they could raise by 50 basis points
meaning raising interest rates more
quickly higher and at a faster pace now
when he said that he's he had never
really said specifically we are open to
raising by 50 basis points he said we're
going to be nimble we're going to do
what's needed
this was kind of his first public
acknowledgement that yes that's on the
table
after that we saw uh a couple other fed
um a couple other fed governors and
federal reserve regional presidents say
the same thing uh some of them who were
voters on this year's committee so we're
going to talk about that why that
matters why that was important and we
don't have any fed speakers with big
speeches right now on the calendar but
we are going to get the fed's favored
measure for inflation we're going to get
a reading on that later this week so
stay tuned i'm going to tell you what
those are while that's important like i
said i think the big themes this week
jobs and inflation and this week is
going to tell us a lot about where both
of those are headed and what we can
expect to see
going forward because we know what's
happened and where we've been
so thanks again for tuning in to the
live stream like i said we're going to
get into all those things and more
right here on market takes
appreciate all of you all who have tuned
in we're going to be like i said diving
into real data real economy looking at
the markets and talking about why all
those things are going to move the
market so here's what we've got coming
up this week we got a big slate of data
today is a light day tomorrow we get the
jolts report which has long been a
favorite of mine i love checking the
jolts report it is a comprehensive
report that tells you all about what's
happening in the labor market this is
the job openings and labor turnover
survey for those of you all who are
interested in some useless trivia
the jolts report
investors had largely ignored that i
think um you know coming into
this year but as we've seen this really
unprecedented environment in the jobs
market i think that has really gotten a
lot more attention from investors and
from folks on wall street who are seeing
hey this is really telling us about
what's going on with the great
resignation what's going on with
hiring why we're seeing so many job
openings
even though there's still all these
folks on the sidelines who lost their
jobs in you know march april may of 2020
and i think we're still not seeing those
folks get back in the job market even
though we've got over 11 million job
openings so we'll get the jolts report
on tuesday we've also got the adp
payrolls report
not a huge market mover but i like it
because it's a report directly from the
payrolls processor it's not an estimate
it's not a survey adp actually gives you
their data they tell you who's getting
paychecks and who's not so that's big on
wednesday and of course we get the big
kahuna the non-farm payrolls report from
the labor department on friday
that's always a market mover but i think
this time
not for the reason that it usually is so
we'll talk all about that
remember we got that 678 thousand
number back in january or for january in
february or in march excuse me and
that's
we'll see if we get another big blowout
number like that there are expectations
for a high date for a high number
we also get pce personal consumption
expenditures that is the fed's favored
measure for inflation we're going to get
that data on wednesday so stay tuned and
buckle up for that
you know people you and i folks out
there we usually watch the cpi the
consumer price index but the pc is what
the fed watches that number's been lower
but historically it's still been at
40-year highs and even the core index
which takes out food and energy which
are two things that have really been
just skyrocketing off the charts even
that has been at the highest in nearly
40 years so we're going to want to watch
for that also on the housing front again
watching housing the federal housing
finance authority or federal housing
finance agency is going to be releasing
its index for the national housing and
we're also going to get the case-shiller
home price index both for january a
little bit delayed but those reports are
very comprehensive and it's what people
are talking about so you'll want to
watch those
looking back at last week
i told you the big event was jerome
powell's speech at nabe the national
association of business economics where
he talked about you know potentially
doing 50 basis points to me this was
powell's whatever it takes moment for
inflation you know after the the covid
pandemic hit in 2020 powell came out
whatever it takes we saw the fed was
really willing to do whatever it took to
support the market really unprecedented
measures they've now pumped about four
trillion dollars out into the economy so
when jerome powell says whatever it
takes the market knows that he means
whatever it takes and this looked like
his moment on uh on inflation saying
we're gonna do what it takes
potentially 50 basis point increases at
meetings double the normal pace um and
and the market reacted we saw bond
yields across the yield curve the two
year the three year in the belly the
five the seven year the ten year
all rising pretty significantly and
again we saw the inversion today the
five year over the 30 year which means
we're seeing short-dated treasuries rise
faster than long-dated and now you're
getting paid higher yield for a
five-year treasury note that's a
bond from the u.s government than you
are for a 30-year treasury bond from the
government which you know if you just
think about it
you should be getting paid more when you
let the government borrow money for 30
years and if they borrow for five years
that's switching
we also heard from cleveland fed
president loretta mester and we also
heard from st louis president
st louis fed president james bullard
both saying yep we're looking at 50
basis points when you look at the market
the market has raised expectations for
the federal reserve to hike rates by at
least 50 basis points at its next two
meetings uh so this is being priced in
and that's moving yields way up
and you know it's going to be more
expensive to borrow that affects you and
i whether we're you know trying to get a
mortgage the mortgage rate is
significantly higher than it has been in
just the past month we've seen a
significant increase in mortgage rates
it's probably gonna hit credit cards
student loans all those things get moved
based on where these treasury yields are
so that's definitely moving the market
goldman sachs city bank of america all
significantly raising their expectations
for rate hikes from federal reserve this
year and that moves the needle that's
big
bond yields up by about 35 basis points
last week from the two-year and to the
10-year the three year actually gaining
by almost 40 basis points i think that's
particularly interesting um the stock
market really seemed to shake that off
though you saw the s p 500 gaining 1.8
percent last week uh the largest
two-week returns we're really seeing
this consistent rise right now in stocks
even though we're seeing those bond
yields really tick up the market kind of
shaken that off which is unusual for the
behavior that we've seen probably over
the past years we've seen rates rise
like i said the s p rising 1.8 percent
last week
that finished a two-week period which
was its best two weeks since november of
2020. that tells you right we saw big
moves in 2020 the nasdaq which has all
those tech stocks high flyers we also
saw
that rise by two percent last week
outgaining the s p 500 even in this
rising yield environment this week i
think is going to be key to seeing does
the market continue to just shake off
those guilds or does this environment
really start to shake investor
confidence that's going to be big to
watch and i think really going to be
telling about the shape of the market as
i talked about earlier
s p 500 on the verge of getting out of
correction territory we are looking to
need about 50 uh 50 50 points gained on
the s p to move out of correction
territory if we do that that's going to
be i think telling of where the market
is where sentiment is all those things
so
looking this week now that was last week
we're in this week
we've got no big speech from powell no
big fed speech is planned but like i
said we get that pce data personal
consumption expenditures that is the
fed's favorite measure for inflation
whenever you hear jerome powell or
anyone else from the federal reserve
talking about inflation they're talking
about pce
and pce
last rating or the last reading excuse
me was it 6.1 percent highest since 1982
even the core index taking out volatile
food and energy prices right to get a
more stable reading of what the economy
is really doing because we know food and
energy move pretty significantly you get
a lot of volatility that measure was the
highest since 1983. 5.2 percent
analysts economists are expecting to see
a 6.4
increase in pce when we get the reading
on wednesday again that means inflation
is rising not peaked not coming down if
we do get that that could be worrisome
for the markets so definitely something
to keep in mind and to be sure that
you're looking out for that pc number
this week is going to be i think the big
kahuna
uh of data if you will
also we're going to get some housing
data i know that folks haven't been
watching that quite as closely but the
housing data i think is going to be big
the federal housing finance agency's
national price index is going to be
coming out along with the case-shiller
national price index housing a big part
of the inflation story and housing
really has been just taking off and it's
one of the things that gets slowly
factored into these inflation reports so
you're going to want to look at housing
because a lot of folks you know whether
you're a renter or buyer these housing
prices influence what you pay so
definitely something to keep an eye on
and to watch out for um
economist we got the new new home sales
report last week uh new home sales
account for about 11.4 of all home sales
we saw that rise by about 10.7 percent
last week or sorry last month excuse me
so again
that's something to watch out for the
other piece of that is actual home sales
declining as prices are rising so in
this rising rate environment where
mortgage rates now are four and a half
percent we're approaching that four and
a half percent number um housing prices
continue to rise and we're seeing folks
mortgages mortgage payments as a share
of family income hitting about 20
percent we're also seeing rents rise by
about 17
uh and that's pretty significant um you
know we've we're already at a record
high rent prices at a record high
feeding all that into inflation
that's something that gets factored in
slowly and as these prices continue to
rise we could see inflation continue to
rise with it so
again that's going to be i think the big
report pc but also watch out for those
housing reports watch out for the jolts
number on tuesday uh that's the big one
and watch out for that jobs number nfps
the labor department's non-farm payrolls
report coming out on friday that's
everything that we've got coming up this
week i think all of those reports could
be market movers
you know as you look out at the markets
right now we're going to check back in
we're seeing the dow still negative but
the s p has actually gotten to about
even it's up about 0.2
[Music]
right now so just in the green the
nasdaq still in the green up by about
half a percent so you know the market
right now seems to be holding steady we
don't have a lot of a lot of data coming
out today but it does seem like the
market
is you know hanging in there after last
week's big rise like i said we've had
the best two-week performance since
november 2020 on the s p 500 and since
april actually on the nasdaq
we're also of course watching oil right
now sinking a bit like a stone
oil down about seven and a half percent
right now so keep an eye on crude
hopefully that feeds into those gas
prices brings those down a little bit
because we have seen significant uh
price appreciation in the price of oil
which is increasing that price that you
all pay at the pump listen um
make sure you're watching the markets
make sure you are watching the data i
hope that you'll keep watching market
takes we will be back with you next
monday i'm dionne robowen for the wall
street journal uh and i appreciate you
guys tuning in everyone that tuned in on
the live stream we hope you'll be back
with us next week when we do this again
here on market takes on youtube on the
wall street